[Music]
we're breaking the programming with
developing news this from the white
house sources tell cbs news
that osama bin laden the leader of al
qaeda is dead
exactly ten years ago tonight president
barack obama announced
the killing of osama bin laden following
a middle of the night raid
in pakistan the american people did not
choose this fight
it came to our shores and started with
the senseless
slaughter of our citizens
[Music]
bin laden the mastermind behind the
attacks of september 11 2001
the deadliest terrorist attack in human
history
was found in the early morning of may
2nd pakistan time
when navy seals burst into his compound
in abadabad
his death ended a global search that
began well before 9 11
as bin laden began coordinating terror
attacks against the west in the 1990s
including u.s embassy bombings in kenya
and
tanzania in 1998 and the bombing of the
uss
cole in october 2000. following 911
a 25 million dollar price tag was put on
bin laden's head
but the search still stymied american
intelligence
bin laden stopped using cell phones in
1998
so the focus turned to the couriers he
used to communicate
when bin laden was finally located on
the third floor of his compound
he was shot by navy seals in the head
and chest
and quickly buried at sea
the news of his death was met with
celebrations
across the country
[Applause]
on nights like this one we can say to
those families who have lost loved ones
to al qaeda's terror justice has been
done
hard to believe it's been 10 years
especially since the last year has felt
like 10 years
just by itself and then of course this
september marks 20 years
since 9 11. yeah i i do remember that
moment when you say you remember where
you were
i remember being at home in that moment
and brian applegate our executive
producer just said this and he's right
there was this
sense of relief for so many because of
what had been caused and you thought at
that point maybe now things will change
and things are over but here we are 10
years after the death of osama bin laden
and there's still u.s forces
in iraq in afghanistan as that war winds
down